may not be the city's favorite team
anymore but the days of the cleveland
indians taking the field
are numbered it's official the team
threw a curveball this morning
by announcing they will change the name
to the guardians effective
at the end of the 2021 season the
decision ends 100 over 100 years of
indian's history
bob feller manny ramirez by the board so
to speak
and it follows a similar move made by
last year's washington
one-time redskins and now the washington
football club
formerly the redskins who changed their
name following a public
outcry they'll name make it another
official name soon
so what is the right call in these
politically correct times are these
teams abandoning their history
let's ask legendary washington redskins
quarterback
super bowl champion his own right author
of this book how to be a champion every
day it's excellent
joe theismann welcome joe i thought
you'd be perfect
you are proud of the history of the
redskins and now the washington football
club
did the cleveland indians make the right
move today you know brian i think it's a
sign of the times
socially i i really believe that this is
what uh we're dealing with
uh you see names being changed uh you're
never gonna get rid of the history i
mean we won three world champions as the
washington redskins
cleveland has had success as a franchise
as the cleveland indians
those are things i hope and pray will
remain but
i i say this to those young people that
are going to be a part of those
franchises going forward
it's your turn to create a new legacy
it's your
turn to create something under a new
name and like i said
it's it's a sign of the times that we're
living in it's the pressures that people
are under
whether it's economic pressure whether
it's outcries whatever it might be
um it's just something that is here and
to right cry over spilt milk just
wouldn't do any good
so i think you have to accept it move
forward with it gotcha um you know
there's a lot of history in cleveland
there was a lot of history with the
washington
franchise going all the way back what 87
years
but now it's time to i think have to
open our eyes and say okay now we're
moving to another era another time
and another place for young players so
here's the question uh they're talking
now about the
kansas city chiefs you know i didn't
think the word chief was a
insult i thought it showed leadership uh
braves
it's the way you fight a lot of people
thought the native american community is
not on the same page in this
do you expect this to be next well i'm
certainly gonna
i would assume that there's gonna be
conversations about it exactly what
happens i mean
let's take the florida state seminoles
as an example
basically the seminoles have basically
said don't touch our football team don't
touch florida state
we're not changing the name so that's a
group that has stood up and said it's
not going to happen
i don't know what's going to happen in
kansas city and i'm not sure what's
going to happen in atlanta
atlantis basically said we'll get rid of
the the chop
but we want to keep the name so you just
don't know
what pressure is going to come to bear
in the future
to ask these franchises to make the
changes that they'll be asked to make if
they are
we'll see if fighting irish some people
are challenging that and you can relate
to that as a notre dame grad and a
superstar there
let's move on and talk about the nfl
league you know quite well
they decided today they told all 32
clubs that the covet outbreaks
among unvaccinated players could result
in forfeiture of a game they're no
longer going to bend
if teams turn out with too many players
who are on the ir
because of uh getting covet 19. is this
the right move did the league have to
make this
proclamation uh well i think the league
has to make some type of a pro
proclamation brian but but who are you
penalizing if
you forfeit games you're penalizing the
players that have been vaccinated
so what sense does that make that if
there's a forfeiture
both those that have not been vaccinated
and those that have been vaccinated
now will be punished in accordance the
same way it just doesn't seem fair
here's to me there's only one possible
solution
to this situation and that is if you're
not vaccinated right
then you have to treat it like it was in
2020.
you're not going to be in the facility
you're not going to be on the football
team
we will get through this at some point
in time and yes i realize there's the
delta variants and all the other things
that we're talking about but at some
point in time this will be in our
rearview mirror
now the andre hopkins for example yeah
let me read this tweet for everyone at
home
uh here it is he's one of the finest
receivers in football he said quote when
this came out
never thought i would say this but being
in a position to hurt my team because i
don't want to partake
in the vaccine is making me question my
future in the nfl he went on to say he
deleted that tweet he wanted to say he
thinks he could play nine more years
do you understand where he's coming from
some people are reluctant to do it
yes i understand what people are
reluctant to to get vaccinated i have
friends of mine
that have basically said they don't want
to get the vaccination
you know the vaccination does not have
fda approval
the vaccination of the three that we've
talked about
basically have just been approved for
emergency use
now are we in an emergency situation in
this country i think that's the question
but from a player's perspective i still
believe in the freedoms of this country
to be able to choose what you want to
put in your body
and i think it's it's you know i respect
the individuals that are making that
decision
but if you're going to be a league and
you want to protect the
the players in the league you can't ask
guys that have already gone and gotten
vaccinated
to lose a paycheck right because of a
forfeiture
the only real solution would be if
you're not vaccinated
you can't be on the facility and you
can't be a practice and then you find
players that are
and then you move forward i mean it's
the only fair way to do it
and not penalize those that have been
vaccinated joe theismann we asked you to
talk about sports
and the vaccine and a pandemic and you
made the adjustment you're still great
at calling an audible thanks so much
brian thank you great catching up with
you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else